Being a D-Class for the SCP Foundation is
a lot like playing Russian roulette: One day,
you could be assigned to a tickle fight with
a friendly blob of slime, and the next you’re
getting your femurs broken to lure a sadistic
old man back into his containment chamber.
So, when D-9781 was told to simply sit in
an interrogation room and wait, he really
didn’t know what to think.
But the last thing he probably expected to
see when the door behind him creaked open
was for a well-dressed stranger to step in.
This man wasn’t like any member of Foundation
staff the D-Class had ever seen: He was a
short, Caucasian man with a receding hairline
and a neat black mustache.
Instead of the standard lab coat and shirt
normally seen around the facility, this man
wore a black waistcoat, a pair of white gloves,
and a wry smile that betrayed a sinister intent.
He looked like a butler – and not just any
butler, but the quintessential butler.
If you were asked to doodle a cartoon butler,
this would be the man you drew.
The D-Class almost laughed in sheer confusion.
He had no idea that, in a mere moment, he
would be dead.
“What’s the deal with Jeeves?”
He asked with a mocking half-smile, but he
didn’t get to hear a response.
The Butler approached at frightening speeds.
The D-Class, in his last moments on this earth,
saw the glint of something metallic under
the overhead lights, moving too fast for him
to see what it was, and then felt a sharp
pain across his throat.
The Butler was standing beside him now, still
with that wry little smile.
The D-Class could see now that the Butler
was carrying a small buck knife, dripping
with red.
Just as he was piecing together what had happened
to him, the D-Class collapsed onto the table
he was sitting at, his throat expertly slit.
His grisly task completed, the Butler gave
a polite nod, and exited the room – smiling
at the Foundation guards standing outside.
Who is this man?
Why is he dressed like this?
And most importantly, why is he allowed to
murder D-Class personnel on Foundation grounds
without consequence?
We can answer that first question right now
- because this isn’t a man at all, he’s
the anomalous product of SCP – 662, also
known as The Butler’s Hand Bell.
First we need to go back to the beginning,
and see how this anomalous object first fell
into the hands of the SCP Foundation.
Like a lot of anomalous objects now under
the care of the Foundation, its true origins
remain mysterious, and it spent quite some
time underground.
We mean that literally, by the way - it was
buried with its last owner, a man whose name
has since been redacted from Foundation files.
Clutched in this unknown man’s skeletal
hand, it was extremely likely that the bell
might never have been seen again.
But then a petty thief and grave robber by
the name of George Dixon came along and dug
up the grave.
A simple, greedy act that has changed a number
of people’s lives forever.
Not knowing the true value of what he held,
Mr. Dixon made his way to a pawnshop for his
payday.
There, the store owner made the mistake of
lifting up and ringing the bell.
As if on cue, he heard footsteps approaching
behind him.
The store owner turned and gasped.
He saw a complete stranger emerging from the
stock-room behind him.
He was a short, well-dressed man, smiling
as he advanced towards him.
The proprietor of the pawnshop didn’t know
who this guy with the strange outfit was,
but he assumed he was an accomplice of the
man in his store and that the two were trying
to rob him.
He grabbed a shotgun from underneath his counter,
turned to The Butler and blasted him in the
chest with both barrels.
The Butler fell back, dead, and George Dixon
fled the scene in a blind panic.
Contrary to what the owner may have believed,
nothing that’d happened here had been planned.
Dixon was just as surprised as he was to see
this mysterious Butler emerge from the stockroom.
So what had just happened?
The pawn shop owner reported the incident
to the authorities and the Butler’s body
was taken to the local morgue, while the silver
bell ended up in a police evidence locker.
Later that same night, things went from a
strange bungled robbery to a full-on anomaly,
attracting the attention of the SCP Foundation.
First, the Butler's body disappeared from
the morgue the second the mortician took her
eyes off of it, and then reappeared, now alive,
in the police storage locker.
Why?
Because an unwitting sergeant just so happened
to ring the little silver bell.
Agent Bradford of the SCP Foundation was promptly
on the scene.
He pretended to be an FBI Agent, and escorted
The Butler off of the premises - claiming
that this was a notorious escape artist who
was wanted for federal crimes in several states.
Things didn’t go as Bradford planned though,
when he discovered that The Butler had disappeared
from his handcuffs when no one was looking.
Agent Bradford theorized that this had to
have something to do with the bell, and he
confiscated it for testing.
Later, when he rang the bell inside an SCP
Containment Facility, The Butler turned up
once more.
He introduced himself as Mr. Deeds and said
that he would happily perform any service
that Agent Bradford required.
Despite being offered the phenomenal power
of a seemingly magical butler, Bradford politely
refused the offer and instead handed the bell
over to his superiors.
But don’t worry, Agent Bradford wasn’t
left completely empty handed and was given
the esteemed SCP Foundation “Pat On The
Back” award for performing such a professional
and selfless act in service of the Foundation.
The superior who ended up with the bell, however,
wouldn’t have quite the same level of professionalism.
But more on that later.
The bell, catalogued as SCP - 662, was small
and made of pure silver, with no obvious anomalous
elements at face value.
It was a mere four centimeters tall and two
centimeters wide, with a small inscription
reading “Forever Mine – S.J.W.”
Researchers studying the bell also noted that
it lacked its ringer, but whenever the bell
was rung, a chime would still sound from somewhere
in the room to signal the arrival of Mr. Deeds,
the anomalous Butler.
The object was classified as Safe, and was
kept in High Value Storage locker 23C between
uses for experiments.
It’s an extremely low-maintenance anomaly,
with the only real requirement being a regular
polish to keep the silver from tarnishing
over time.
But what of Mr. Deeds, the mysterious Butler
summoned every time someone rings SCP - 662?
The Foundation needed to find out more, so
he was placed under the watchful eye of Foundation
researcher Dr. Mirth, who performed the first
interview with Mr. Deeds.
As you can probably expect from such a classy
servant, Mr. Deeds was unfailingly polite
during the interview.
He always addressed Dr. Mirth as Sir, and
was extremely accommodating - within reason.
Mr. Deeds’ true name, birthplace, and date
of birth were still a mystery to him.
He could only vaguely remember that he was
of English ancestry, and that during the time
of his childhood, the horse and buggy was
the most popular form of transport.
When asked about personal details or his past,
Mr. Deeds would often appear to become distressed,
before apologizing for his inability to remember
the details.
The most important piece of information that
Dr. Mirth obtained early on in the interview
was the primary function of Mr. Deeds: He
was an entity that quite literally lived to
serve.
Like a genie being summoned from his lamp,
Mr. Deeds would try to perform any task that
the summoner gave him - whether it was cooking
dinner or robbing banks.
There were certain limits to these powers
though, and these limits were what Dr. Mirth
needed to discover.
Dr. Mirth first asked for a glass of iced
tea from Mr. Deeds.
The Butler happily obliged, and left the room,
walking down the hallway.
While attending agents kept their eyes on
him, Mr. Deeds continued to merely walk.
However, the second they looked away, the
cameras observing him malfunctioned, Deeds
briefly disappeared, and then returned with
a tray of iced tea.
Dr. Mirth remarked that it was perhaps the
best iced tea he’d ever tasted.
Mr. Deeds couldn’t recall how the tea was
made though, or how he obtained it.
Dr. Mirth next asked for a bar of gold at
99.98% purity, and Mr. Deeds delivered almost
the exact level of purity Dr. Mirth asked
for.
From this, he deduced that Mr. Deeds can only
perform his teleportation and manifestation
abilities when he’s out of people’s direct
lines of sight.
He soon discovered that certain requests were
off the table though.
Dr. Mirth asked for Mr. Deeds to fetch him
a blue 1963 Corvette convertible.
Mr. Deeds did not immediately procure the
car, instead telling the doctor that such
a thing was impossible because there were
too many impractical steps involved in getting
the vehicle.
Dr. Mirth was disappointed by this, since
he really wanted that car.
It seemed as though Mr. Deeds’ powers, while
enhanced by teleportation and the ability
to manifest simple objects, are limited by
things that a mostly normal, and very persistent
person could conceivably do.
For example, on Dr. Mirth’s orders, Mr.
Deeds politely declined to assassinate an
insurgent leader in the Middle East - seeing
as he was too well-guarded and very far away.
However, when given the command, he was more
than willing to head into the next room and
murder a member of D-Class with a knife.
Dr. Mirth was interested in getting a closer
look at what was going on with Mr. Deeds’
biology, and so asked him to slit his own
throat with the same knife he used to murder
the D-Class.
Mr. Deeds politely obliged, commenting before
he did to Dr. Mirth that it’d been an absolute
pleasure serving him.
The body was kept within an agent’s line
of sight at all time until the autopsy could
be performed, just to make sure it didn’t
disappear.
The autopsy showed that there was nothing
inherently anomalous about the physiology
of Mr. Deeds, and he would appear, as good
as new, the next time that the bell rang.
Things took an even stranger turn after that
though.
Despite it appearing like the Foundation now
knew everything they needed to know about
Mr. Deeds and the SCP - 662 bell, Dr. Mirth
insisted on performing further studies into
what exactly Mr. Deeds was capable of.
For example, he requested a deep tissue massage,
and found that it completely cured his back
pain.
Dr. Mirth also asked Mr. Deeds to clean his
car, and found that it was cleaned to a truly
impeccable standard.
During his tenure as the lead researcher on
the 662 project, he also asked to receive
a haircut from Mr. Deeds - and found out that
while Mr. Deeds excelled at many tasks, he
made a pretty bad barber.
He was great at laundry though.
Dr. Mirth was eventually removed from 662
duty by the O5 Council, once it became clear
his “research” had just become an excuse
for Mr. Deeds to do errands and chores for
him.
Of course, Mr. Deeds had no complaints either
way.
Whether it’s serving up delicious tea, cleaning
a certain selfish researchers’ home, or
murdering a D-Class personnel with a buck
knife, one thing cannot be denied - Mr. Deeds
is one hell of a Butler.
Now go watch “SCP - 066 - Eric’s Toy”
and “SCP - 4999 - Someone To Watch Over
Us Tale.” for more of the best stories straight
from the SCP foundation!